foreign
[Music]
Spaceport here in French Guiana and to
your front row seat for the launch of
the Jupiter icy moons Explorer on an
Aryan 5 rocket
our rocket is here on the launch pad
with the Drew spacecraft on top ready to
begin is strong
over the next couple of hours we will
renew live coverage of launch operations
directly from here the Jupiter control
center
in Germany
[Music]
this is where we're getting the first
signals from the spacecraft after launch
and confirmation that the solar panels
have deployed we'll be discussing
exactly what makes this spacecraft so
special
I'm Matt Russell I'm Bruno Souza I'm
Rafael and I'm Lisa Peterson and welcome
to flight VA 260 on the first leg of
Juicy's journey into space
there she is the Ariane 5 rocket
Standing Tall on her launch pad here at
Europe Spaceport in French Guyana with
her single passenger today the Jupiter
icy moons Explorer juice safe and sound
under the fairing ready for liftoff in
just under half an hour
I'm here in the Jupiter Mission Control
Center and we are some 12 kilometers
away from the launch fed and here on the
other side of this protective wall which
we call the Fishbowl here in Jupiter you
can see the operational teens hard at
work getting it ready with the last
preparations for today's launch opposite
me here we have Partners VIPs and guests
all waiting for liftoff comfortably
seated and they are among the Happy Well
the very lucky few who will get to see
the liftoff with their own eyes they'll
feel it as well from The Terraces on
either side here of Jupiter and I'm very
happy to welcome Stefan Israel CEO of
Aryan space welcome to rotor space
Stefan good morning Liz so you're here
to give us an update on the situation
but first of all a very very special
Mission today with an outstanding
passenger under the fairing of Aryan
five for sure truth is an outstanding
Mission I mean this Mission has involved
more than 21 Partners around
defense and space and so today is a very
important day for us because this
mission is a unique mission towards the
Peter it is the start of ATL trolley and
uh is this type of mission a particular
challenge for your teams here so this is
assertive scientific Mission iron space
is going to deliver for either and the
most recent one have been James Webb and
before BP Colombo so we know how to
deliver them but it is an escape orbit
so it means that after 27 minutes of
flight we will have given to the Jews a
speed of more than 10 kilometers per
second to a low juice to escape from the
earth attraction so this is what we are
going to deliver today
and what's the situation
at the moment I can see everything is
green on the status board yes so
everything is green and so to liftoffs
you need three parameters to remain
green to the very end so long channels
the launcher should be ready and up two
thousand launcher is ready those should
be ready and up to now juice is ready
and the final parameter which is very
important is the weather and we will
make two last check for the weather 20
minutes before the launch and 10 minutes
before the launch and we will see what
will be the situation at this moment
thank you so much Stefan I'm going to
let you get back into the Fishbowl where
you're heading up the flight desk and
we'll speak to you right after
separation thank you so much thank you
Elise
so of course launch operations are
underway here final preparations but
some 7 500 kilometers away over the
Atlantic in darmstadt Germany at the
European space agency's mission control
the operational teams that are going to
take over control of the spacecraft once
it's separated from the mothership are
on standby and we're going to go
straight over to darmstadt and hear how
things are going over there over to you
Matt
thank you
ah thank you Lisa and hello to our
Watchers welcome to esoc the European
space operations center facility here in
damstat Germany in the heart of the
mission control center of operations my
name is Matt Russell and I'll be your
host for this second half of this really
special juice broadcast and put behind
the glass here we have our resident
expert Bruno Susa who is a deputy
director flight director for juice hello
Bruno can you give us an update of
what's exactly happening now in the
mission control
thanks Matt everybody's getting
Goosebumps over here just a few minutes
ago flight director Andrea Komatsu gave
us a roll call and I think we have
footage of that and we're going to show
it to you right now
to all stations this is a day on The
Briefing Loop for the Roll Call of the
Jews mission
please reply to my call with your course
sign and Status Quo or no go om o m oh
some some go
data handling
CS go platform platform go fly Dynamics
Academic School
project right
go project support project support go
soft chord soft chord
go
software support software support go
extract extra go scheduling scheduling
go thanks this completes the roll call
for juice we are go for launch
so we're all ready for launch just
waiting for the rocket to get out of the
launch pad back to you Matt
as you can see everything's ready for
launch uh over to you back over to you
Lisa in karoo
March mad and it was a great actually to
see people whooping here as they heard
that everything is ready to go so we
heard it from isoc operations
operational teams already over there the
spacecraft is ready here in Kuru but
what about juice well I'm with Michaela
and you're going to tell us from ASA and
you're going to tell us
what you know how is juice doing is
juice ready good morning Lisa yes juice
is ready as the project team where our
story it has been years since we have
been waiting for this moment and we are
all very excited as we speak my
colleagues are a few kilometers away in
LBC control room and yesterday evening
at 7 15 PM the satellite has been
switched on and together with the flight
operators we are closely monitoring it
as we speak it has been quite an
intensive launch campaign but we are in
excellent spirits and we are excited to
watch choose starting this journey today
towards Jupiter and its icy moons as
planned fantastic you say as planned
because your role is scheduled
controller huge responsibility does that
mean you're in charge of making sure it
takes off as planned
I took my responsibility yes but when
you speak about scheduling an agency is
not one person's job actually it's a
team exercise and that's the juice
project team we are so schedule oriented
we have a strong planning mindset and if
you take a step back and you look at the
impressive Mission we are seeing today
you have 10 state-of-the-art instruments
you have an impressive spacecraft you
have the most large solar arrays ever
flown for interplanetary Mission 85
square meters then you translate all
this information to Milestones you
understand how much work it takes and
how much excellence in project
management
Michaela this when we spoke earlier you
told me this is eight years of your
professional life how are you feeling
today in a nutshell I'm so excited
because honestly for me juice is my
entire career in the agency I was
shortly assigned to this Mission when I
joined and I am exceptionally proud to
be part of this team and I want to say
uh have a good launch to all my
colleagues here on the Spaceport my
colleagues watching now in Aztec my
colleagues in ezoc which are working at
my colleagues in exact have a great
lunch everyone we all worked hard for it
and we all deserve it you absolutely do
thank you so much for being with us
mihaila and so as mihaila was saying so
many years of work for her teams for
teams around the world so we're going to
take a look at their achievements and
we're going to meet our passenger in
this next film
[Music]
Jupiter the largest planet in the solar
system is a place that holds many
Secrets this fascinating gas giant
planet and its intriguing moons have
raised more questions than answers
today these answers are in essa's grasp
but the very first European mission to
Jupiter
juice
short for Jupiter icy moons Explorer the
spacecraft will explore Jupiter and
three of its icy moons Callisto Europa
and a particular Ganymede developed and
built by Airbus juices spacecraft is
equipped with 10 top-of-the-line science
instruments to explore the Jovian system
and investigate whether some of its many
environments may be suitable for the
formation of life
this Grand Odyssey of exploration begins
with the launch of juice on an Aryan 5
rocket from Europe's spacebot in Peru an
historical Mission Amy at solving key
Mysteries such as the possibility of
life in the Jovian system ganymede's
magnetic field and last but not least
the formation of Jupiter and its moons
juice will also study Jupiter's complex
weather chemistry and climate in detail
it's a very fantastic Mission from the
scientific point of view very broad
science very interdisciplinary science
we would like to see whether around
Jupiter there are places where life
could have started to explore that we
need to find a place with the internal
energy and with liquid water and inside
the icy moons we have good reason to
believe that there is in fact more
liquid water out there inside the
surface than on on Earth
juice is expected to arrive at Jupiter
in 2031 and will then make its Jupiter
Tour and Moon's flybys before orbiting
Ganymede this will be the first time a
spacecraft orbits any Moon other than
our own during its Journey Jews will
face many dangers such as Jupiter's
intense radiation belts or its large
gravitational pull but these dangers
will be worth it for the science that
juice will uncover
the gas giant will reveal some of its
many secrets in 2032 when the First Data
will be available
watch this space
and back to us here in Peru so talking
about explorers we have two of the faces
of space exploration with us here today
and I'm very pleased to welcome two of
Europe's most experienced astronauts we
have Matthias Maura and we have Tuma
pesky with us here today so um I have my
first question is for you Matthias
um it's all very well um you know
sending
juice out there but when we go out there
to space send you know
spacecraft's Lake juice what does it
bring us back here on Earth
I think at the beginning of everything
is the human curiosity we humans we want
to understand when you fly to space we
want to understand and learn it's also
applicable in science and technology in
general and once we understand we want
to translate it into applications see
like how can we make our life on Earth
easier better and with the knowledge
that we gained in space and so all the
stuff that we do in space it directly
feeds back into applications just
looking at the huge solar panels of the
probe 85 square meters it's like today
we are talking about Green energy to
have life on Earth more sustainable
without solar panels developed for space
and then spin off onto US applications
this transformation in energy for us
applications would not be possible and I
mean sometimes it takes longer sometimes
the application will come years years
after the science has been done so
thanks to Einstein's relativity Theory
we have now the best navigation system
in the world the Galileo system and
everybody can use this with mobile
application in the hands thank you very
much so um we're sending juice out on
its Journey today but um what about the
upcoming destinations for human space
exploration yes so we humans we can
unfortunately not yet travel at such
distance to Jupiter so we fly to Lewes
the International Space Station and once
this will end we will continue with new
more modern platforms but then we also
continue exploration we are part of the
Artemis program Esa is an essential part
of of NASA with the European service
module so we will be flying to the moon
and Toma and I and our colleagues from
the astronaut core we are dreaming of
flying the first Europeans to the Moon
being among them and hopefully stepping
also on the planet and it shall be a
continuous present on the moon and on
moon we will learn a lot for technology
that we spin back to Earth applications
but we will also learn for later on for
Missions to Mass
so talking about you know going to the
Moon I mean um tomorrow are you getting
ready to you know take part in any of
these missions that Matthias is telling
us about I think I think we are I think
Esa made the Bold decision to send
Europe onto this adventure which was the
right decision to make
um I think we we have a variety of
destinations today we should not forget
lowers orbit and the International Space
Station or friend and colleague Andreas
morgenson he's now in the final stretch
for his mission launching in August and
then we'll have a rotation of mission
missions to laws orbit we have new
colleagues who have just started at the
European astronaut Center and we're glad
to have them there's going to be so many
missions to fly in the future and
obviously the Artemis missions
everybody's trying to you know do their
part everybody's trying to contribute
what they've learned in space what
they've learned before to go as a team
and that's what we're focusing on for
the years to come so I hear the two of
you telling me that you're both able and
ready to go do you see yourself taking
off from Europe's Spaceport here in
French Guiana I think it'd be a dream
but it's more than a dream because we're
having this conversation we're working
on this independent you know access to
space for humans from French Guyana we
have all the building blocks you know
we've had we've had a reliable launcher
Arya and five Aryan 6 is going to follow
suit we've had the ATV the transfer
vehicle we've had the CRV the return
vehicle we have space Rider we have
everything we have all the building
blocks we just have to put them together
and for this you need a vision I think
we have the vision that we need a
mandate but tomorrow you can imagine now
that Europe is more mature now that
Europe is you know growing on the scene
people feel more and more European
sometimes because of the crisis around
us but at least the result is we're
being more united and I think that would
be a fantastic project to kind of
inspire Europe and to channel the best
that Europe has to offer and to make
Europeans dream for generations to come
thank you very much stay with us because
we have Joseph ashba and said thank you
so much for joining us you are Esa
director General well a very simple
question to you I mean you know we're
talking here about you know the
capability of space Explorations are you
going to make this happen
it needs a lot of people to make this
happen but of course my job is like the
channel of Visa is to to make sure that
the discussion takes place and that we
have a discussion in Europe and
preparing decisions in order to make
this happen in fact we just received a
report from a high level Advisory Group
called Revolution space and it really
means a revolution for Europe in space
to really engage bring Europe one level
uh higher in uh in space exploration
literally and make sure that Europe has
all these capabilities which Tomah and
Matthias have just described so yes sir
uh we're doing we're doing everything to
make it happen but at least today we're
here in front of the screens of choose
let's talk about choose because that's
such an exciting Mission thank you so
much Joseph thank you Toma but yes thank
you very much for being with us it was a
pleasure thank you
so for those of you who are joining us
we are yeah just under 12 minutes to
lift off we're here I'm here in Jupiter
control uh we're about to see Aryan five
take off with juice under its fairing uh
heading for Jupiter and I am here with
Rafael from Aryan space Rafael is going
to take us through every step along the
way of this Mission welcome to rotor
space hello Liz so um why don't we just
take us through maybe the next steps
coming up now absolutely so I'm in five
this morning is going to launch towards
the east so at such low latitude we
benefit from what we call the slingshot
effect given by the rotation of the
earth providing enough speed for juice
the launcher first performs a pitch
maneuver to get into the required
Direction and only two minutes and 17
seconds after this stuff the two
boosters have done their jobs of
providing enough the main thrust and
they are detached from the launcher and
shortly after that the fairing which
protected
spacecraft from the frictions of the air
is separated
in two halves as we have crossed the
limits of the atmosphere we just don't
don't need it anymore and once the
launcher reaches an intermediate orbit
the main stage is cut off and separated
we then enter the second
property phase of the flight with the
ignition of the upper stage the engine
powers for about 16 minutes in order to
raise speed and attitude and reach the
targeted orbit for juice the little
towers that we see on the motion picture
represent a chain of telemetry stations
that are receiving data from Iron 5 all
along the flight path
and after some orientation maneuver
juice is separated on a liberation's
orbit meaning it will have the required
speed to escape the gravitational pull
of Gears this is almost the end of the
mission for the launcher perspective as
we still need to perform some disposal
maneuvers of the upper stage but this is
definitely the beginning of the journey
for juice
will use the Northside ground Telemetry
stations in Australia
to acquire signal from the spacecraft
and take full control of it
we're bringing you this information live
I'll actually listen to what's being
said in French and I'll come back to you
and Translate
sounds like we're heading for
there is a risk of lightning right yes
right it's been announced so Maya and
Claire has just announced that we're
going to Halt the launch uh the launch
operations for now for today due to
weather conditions but what does this
mean Raphael so it means that we usually
check
um whether the winds at high altitude
the winds in the vicinity of the
Launchpad and also the risk of lightning
is the last latest criteria that is not
suit for a launch today unfortunately
exactly out of our control but he also
reminds you that we don't take any risk
when it comes to launching a satellite
absolutely absolutely so as Rafael was
saying
um it's been announced that for for
today the liftoff is going to be
postponed of course this passenger is
safe and sound under the Fairing and
will of course be bringing you all the
information on a new date as soon as we
get it we have Stefan Israel who is
going to come and make a an announcement
to us
right now
Stefan welcome back Sirens faster than
we had imagined yes but
it's beyond our control right yes for
sure you know uh it's a part of our
business and what is important is when
you lift off you must make sure that all
the barometers are green again the
Longshore was okay juice was okay but
the final checks made by kness on the
weather were not okay you have two
reasons not to lift off high altitude
winds or risk of lightening the High
Altitude winds were okay there was a
risk of lightening so now you see a red
on the screen what is important is that
the launcher and Juice are in stable
configuration and in full security we
will be back tomorrow morning
is tomorrow morning and of course
at 9 15 it's going to be 9 14 as you
said so we will see you all tomorrow at
more or less the same time and we'll
hope that the weather is going to be
more Clement tomorrow a little bit of
passions and it would be okay tomorrow
yes well thank you very much Stefan and
well be assured that juice is safe and
sound under the fairing it's just going
to be you have to be a little more
patient another 24 hours let's hope
that's it from us thank you Stefan
thank you